it's great to welcome back to the
program today thomas frank who is author
of
the people know a brief history of
anti-populism
also author of listen liberal and what's
the matter with kansas
and other books uh it's great to have
you back on today
you know david it is my pleasure so
let's to pick a place to start because
we could start in many different places
do you believe that the democratic party
as an institution
has accurately ascertained why donald
trump won in 2016.
well no of course not there they've done
anything but but
uh but examined that they're uh they've
been in denial ever since that election
now
i i think that there is some um that
they understand it and it's not hard to
understand you know you've got this uh
large group of voters that has been
moving over to the shifting over to the
republican
party for a long long long time
and uh in reaction to you know these
very predictable things
not not predictable but visible i should
say very highly visible
developments so it's not like it's hard
to understand
what what's going wrong uh but
they are you know you think about uh
they spent
several years investigating uh
you know investigating trump's
supposedly being a
you know some kind of russian agent you
know collusion with the with the with
the russians
and you know whether or not that look
trump's administration is corrupt eight
ways to sunday but
the the the uh the intention there was
always to try to
somehow pin the election results on this
outside actor and
in this way dismiss what happened uh and
so
no they haven't and they've done
anything but
reckon with what happened in 2016 except
for in one way
but it's more subconscious than anything
else and that is the choice of joe biden
i mean biden is actually
i i i think he's more interesting than
other people do
um because he is he does come from this
sort of old
uh sort of uh working-class background
or at least
you know they tell us that all the time
he used to call himself middle class
joe and he rides the amtrak and on and
on and on
and so in that respect they have chosen
someone who they think
will uh uh will bring back the uh you
know the sort of uh
manufacturing areas that they lost uh
pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin maybe even ohio and we shall
see but that's
biden is basically the one man they
could choose to do that job without
actually going to a sort of bernie
sanders kind of figure
yeah one of the things that i found
interesting is that
there are there's no candidate that is
beyond critique
i am against the deification of any
elected official these are just people
and sometimes we'll agree with them and
sometimes we'll disagree with them
but i think that not enough attention
has been paid which is why i've been
trying to pay attention to
to some of the interesting policy
proposals that joe biden is putting
forward
where i mean listen when you look at
uncapping social security tax at 400 000
that's that's huge that that's radical
in circles
but that's not no one's gonna notice
that or or you know yeah
so that's my question which is what is
there just
is there no piece of the electorate that
actually cares about something
like economic policy oh my god well of
course they do care
but only only when you deliver the
results i mean of course they
look everybody is you know my grand
theory about
about uh what's been happening in
politics and i've been writing about it
you know low these many years yeah is
that we are uh
we are in fact furious about economic
developments
uh you know ever since the early 1980s
this country has
for most people been on a downhill uh
you know on a toboggan ride to nowhere
yeah uh you know the the the middle
class society that i was born into is
long gone people are furious about it
de-industrialization etc etc etc
no people don't understand the nuts and
bolts of how that was done
uh but they do get the big picture uh
absolutely they get it but they uh you
know something like that it's gonna be
it's gonna be i mean you can explain it
to people in a way that uh that makes
sense and
that is actually compelling you know
that that the rich should pay their fair
share et cetera
but you've got a you've got to have a a
whole vision a whole understanding of
uh you know of the of this the situation
that people are in
you can't just promise technocratic
fixes that will you know that
that'll that'll you know make the
machine run slightly more smoothly
and i hate to say it but this is kind of
donald trump's
strength is that he talks like uh you
know
he's constantly complaining even though
he's president yeah he could beat the
plane's cause
i was just reading something the other
day where he was he was uh
he was actually blaming some policy
disaster
on biden and it's something that's like
right now
and it's like how could biden is like
you know in his basement
in delaware he hasn't been in office in
years how could he possibly
be held responsible this is just trump's
way of talking you know well i wanted to
ask about that because i did a segment a
couple of weeks ago talking about how
donald trump has adopted rhetoric of
even though he's president
running as if someone else is president
and you should elect him you know
he's like if you get if you re-elect me
i'll build the wall i'll fix taxes i'll
do healthcare
also he thinks this way or he appears to
i mean i don't know how
much his you know you should how much
emphasis you should put on his twitter
feed but like uh
here's a guy that keeps talking about
like how
somebody should do something about
google right he's like
you're the president just you know call
your
attorney general into the room and
instruct him to go get those guys
it's really not hard but my question
about the running as if he's not
president is
who is that tailored to appeal to is
that tailored to appeal to people who
aren't
paying close attention is it tailored to
appeal to to his existing base to
moderates what what is
what is it about clearly the first
criteria is
is people who as you as you just said
who aren't paying much attention because
that's
that's
that one it just doesn't it just that
doesn't
i don't think that works for very many
people you know you it's
it's that's a that's a a silly little
psychological trick that is not that i
think is not going to succeed
i mean look this guy is there's also a
um
a bit of wish fulfillment uh there this
guy is
his his tenure in office has been
nothing short of disastrous i mean look
where we are yes
hundreds of thousands of people have
died the economy is basically shut down
uh you know you've got uh uh protests
and
uh uh you know violence in the streets
all over the place
and uh some president this guy you know
he can't do anything about any of it or
or
you know he could but he's just utterly
incompetent and unsuited to the office
i'm uh 55 years old david and
i've seen something we've seen some
incompetent presidents i often think of
jimmy carter you know who just got
so badly swamped after one term in
in 1980 and uh this guy is way
beyond that jimmy carter looks really
like
wonderful by comparison to donald trump
jimmy carter really cared he was really
trying hard it's just nothing worked for
him you know
but this guy oh my god he doesn't have
any idea what he's doing
i want to talk a little bit about in the
in the context of all this
the populous sounding rhetoric that
donald trump has used
when it comes to trade when it comes to
the middle class which in some ways
has overlap with the rhetoric of bernie
sanders although not in policy
certainly yeah um i interviewed federico
finkelstein from the new school
up some time ago and he focuses in
a lot on the difference between
left and right wing populism which often
shares similar rhetoric
and the difference in implementation of
populist rhetoric
by left versus by the right how relevant
do you think that is
to the trump presidency and to the case
that he's making for his re-election
well so you know you're opening up a big
can of worms here but
but there's no doubt about it that trump
speaks in workerist language uh he does
that all the time the sort of grievances
of you know he's managed to
make himself the embodiment of a certain
kind of blue-collar grievance about the
world
but just in in point of fact um just so
you know the man who was responsible for
killing populism in america william
mckinley was the greatest protectionist
of his era
the populists were actually free free
traders they were it was a farmer
movement so of course that's what they
were
but trump sounds like more like mckinley
than than anybody else
when you know when you when you talk
about the reality of it uh but he does
look the the whole secret of
republican domination and of the of the
great
move to the right in this country since
the 1980s has been
a rhetorical discovery by the right this
um
you know so what i what i trace in this
new book of mine that people know is
this long history of
populism which in america refers to a
left-wing
tradition right and uh uh and the way it
was beaten and it was
the you know the right in this country
repeatedly went
after the populists whoever they happen
to be at the time
went after them with this kind of
upper-class aristocratic rhetoric
insisting that you know the lowly get
back in their place
and that's this is a consistent theme in
american life up until
the uh 1960s and 70s when the right
discovered
that you know that's no way to win an
election and the way you win an election
is by actually reaching out to these
sort of disgruntled
uh you know members of the middle class
and uh and and and becoming their their
voice and this is
you know nixon did it uh but reagan was
kind of the master at doing this
remember his sort of old-fashioned frank
capra foxiness
uh trump is excellent at it trump is
very good at that he's a he's a
lousy president but he's he's
rhetorically he's you know he's pretty
good at talk at
you know at this sort of this very uh uh
precise maneuver so um
he does talk like uh like he's part of
that tradition but
as you know think of all the guys i just
named reagan
nixon you could add gingrich to that
list you could add
you know george w bush to that list you
could add george bush senior to that
list
these people don't give a damn about the
working class
they you know they're they're all about
their their agenda is different
they're uh they're after something else
so that's where my concern comes from
thomas when i see
some on the left watch a tucker carlson
segment out of context
and they say you know he's making a lot
of sense there
and then at the tail end of it it's like
and we've got to stop brown people from
coming in from other countries
and black lives matter might take your
house you know you get
it's like the the pot of gold at the end
of the rainbow is horrifying and that's
what worries me about seeing
some on the left say you know we might
have some alliances here
yeah but the the the critical thing to
remember is that
and this is especially the case with
with someone like tucker carlson
is that they they are swiping the
traditional
rhetoric of the left trump too i mean
and
oh my god and the the one who is
probably best at it of anyone is steve
bannon right guy's unreal he says things
that you would hear in a union hall you
know
as you just described then you go and
you look beneath the surface and
and he's recommending something that's
just absolutely dreadful i'll give you
my favorite example from bannon
which is he made a documentary about the
financial crisis i i don't know if any
i don't think anybody's ever i've got a
copy of it a dvd of it around the house
somewhere
and um it starts out and it looks like a
real
documentary about the financial crisis
he quotes a lot has a lot of the same
experts
as other as real documentaries you know
and it starts this footage of
you know the streets of lower manhattan
etc and about
you know but then about 10 minutes in it
takes this crazy turn
and he tries to blame the entire
financial crisis
on the hippies of the 1960s
this is the financial crisis of 2008
mind you and it's like
whoa how the hell does he you know why
would anyone do that
it's because he's you know obviously
because he's trying to claim the
financial crisis for the right which is
in my mind
impossible because it's the result of
you know of of uh deregulation and the
adoption of supply side et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and uh uh you know it's we know why this
happened it wasn't because of the
hippies
so how do you then make sense of because
i just because there are right-wing
politicians
misusing populist rhetoric doesn't mean
that you couldn't form an alliance on
these issues that are important to
everybody
across left and right but then you get
to the difficult question of
is the alliance a productive one or
potentially a dangerous one
if it's these folks who end up in power
as a result of the alliance so i don't
know how parse that
that's no no no i i don't know i don't i
wouldn't say that but form an alliance
with
with with like steve bannon no no no no
no no not with not with the not with the
the uh the players but i mean
an alliance among people on the left and
right who typically would be
in different political constituencies oh
well that's
you're so look you've got this huge
problem in american life of the
you know this huge part of the
electorate that has moved
from left to right in the course of my
lifetime right you've also got
uh uh you know a a slightly smaller
part of the electorate that's gone the
other way the you know you look at
orange county which has gone from being
the most you know conservative you know
home of the john birch society to
voting for hillary clinton last time
around or the county i grew up in in
johnson county kansas which is
very wealthy suburb of kansas city
and when i was a kid you know you know
it was goldwater
country and now it's it'll probably go
for biden
this year i mean it's been slowly
becoming blue but the
the other story is the one that has
always intrigued me which is the
um the the sort of guys who in the 60s
or 70s would have been
union members you know and their
families moving to the republican party
and this is we all know this story these
people voting for
ronald reagan and now voting for trump
etc etc etc
that's uh look you got to win those
people back there's no
question in my mind that that's how
that's that's the
that is the uh you know the rot
that is just that has destroyed the
democratic party and has destroyed the
middle
class society and if you don't deal with
that this is just going to get worse so
hell yes you got to reach out to those
people because
you have to remember that their
interests are fundamentally
on on the on the left their economic
interests and that's what is
that's what is really matter now yeah
trump has deceived them with his talk
about
uh trade and his talk look he
i hate to say it but go back and look at
his speeches in 2016 he
swiped a lot of the language of the left
uh you mentioned him swiping uh bernie
sanders issues
trump pretended to to to be a critic of
wall street do you remember this
yeah and then he gets it off he said the
hedge fund guys aren't going to like me
you know they hired hillary for speeches
but they're not going to hire me they're
not going to like me
yeah on and on and on and then he gets
in office and it's steve mnuchin another
guy from goldman sachs
you know and he deregulates wall street
some more and he deregulates the
polluters some more and he deregulates
everything in
you know in every industry that's what
he does
the thing is that you've got to rebuild
those bridges and the democrats
biden is at least a halting step in that
direction and that's a good thing
but uh but otherwise in policy terms the
democrats have shown little interest in
doing that well i wonder
how you rebuild it because if you think
back to for example the tea party in
2010
it was a movement almost exclusively of
people supporting economic policy
that was not good for them and if you do
an analysis like jonathan height does
a social psychology analysis he says
well as individuals
they were supporting policies that
didn't benefit them but they were they
were on
message with the team with the group
that they chose
how do you get them to recognize they
maybe should look at a different team
well first of all you get out there you
got to remember that what was so
shocking about the tea party movement
and i went to the one of my
very few claims to fame in this life
david pakman
i went to the very first tea party rally
uh do you remember it started with rick
santelli on tv
yelling about something at the chicago
board of trade right and a few
days later the uh conservative movement
here in dc put together a
protest out in lafayette park in front
of the white house
obama had only been in office a few
weeks at this point
and i went to it and i wrote it up for
the wall street journal where i was
writing at the time and i made fun of
them i thought it was ridiculous
but here's something that they figured
out that our
team did not it was a ginned up you know
thing it was a bunch of lobbyists and
think tank personnel saying let's start
a protest movement
at least they were trying you know they
were like let's go out there and
fake a protest movement they don't
really know what a protest movement
looks like a lot of these guys are
wearing suits and ties
i mean for god's sakes when santelli did
his rent he
he was complaining it from the chicago
board of trade if you go back and look
at what he was complaining about
he was complaining about individual
homeowners he wasn't complaining about
wall street he was complaining about
us and if i recall the rent the rant was
something about let's all not pay our
mortgages and see what happened
let's let's you know screw the average
the average american homeowner it's just
it's inconceivable that that would catch
on but it did because it's the only game
in town
like i said i went to a bunch of these
you know these are people who are really
into iron rand ayn rand
hated and despised ordinary americans
you know she's all about the
billionaires and the geniuses and this
kind of thing
and the idea of building that into a
mass movement
is so utterly and completely upside down
but on the other hand you go back and
watch those glenn beck show
glenn beck being their sort of biggest
supporter on tv on fox news at the time
you go back and watch those shows and at
least he was
acknowledging people's anxiety people's
fear
okay the democrats were in by no means
doing this barack obama was in the white
house and immediately came to terms with
the wall street banks and
was all about reassurance um not about
you know uh
you know all about uh uh reaching across
the alligator what's the term consensus
all about consensus it's just we missed
it again you know we had
we had the we i i'm sorry it wasn't
really your fault and it wasn't my fault
but the democrats had the greatest
opportunity in
uh 50 years in their hands
and they let it slip through their
fingers and it's largely thanks to
things like the tea party movement they
were just outplayed
in in you know on the sort of uh
national stage
so the alternative is there has to be
something more appealing than
a tea party movement essentially yes and
so the look the history of populism
in this country is again and again and
again you realize the power of mass
movements of working-class people
ordinary americans
mass movements of ordinary people are
what get the goods
not having you know a bunch of really
smart guys sitting around the cabinet
table in the white house
and and and coming up with a deal with
wall street or coming up with a deal
with big pharma which they then as soon
as they were done with wall street then
they did that right
coming up with a deal with the hospital
association or then later on
obama's career coming up with a deal
with facebook and google
you know that's not how you make change
that's not how you get reform
that's not how you rebuild the the you
know the middle class society you do it
with
mass movements in the street and the
right understands that and so they gin
up these fake protest movements and the
tea party movement is the most
outstanding example but it's by no means
the only one they've been doing this for
years since the 70s
fake protest movements you know anyhow
we've been speaking with thomas frank
we've dabbled a little bit in some of
the content of his latest book the
people
know a brief history of anti-populism
thomas always great having you on david
you know the pleasure is all mine
it really is fun